Trey,
my daddy Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.
Well,
at all tribes,
the nature of tribes,
you tell something that makes your tribe look like the good guys.
Right?
Right.
So each tribe has,
that's,
that's the conservative story.
And then the liberal story is like we're fighting racism and sexism.
Did you see the Golden Globes?
Uh,
I did see the Golden,
did you see the Meryl Streep's?
We did see the Meryl Streep's speech.
God bless her.
God bless marrow.
What'd she was talking about?
Mixed martial arts people got so mad.
And I was like,
of course she doesn't watch cage fighter when she's talking out of her ass for
sure.
But she,
you know to say that some people aren't artists,
martial artists aren't artists.
Well that's completely open to interpretation.
Like what do you think is beautiful?
You think that fucking stupid movie when you played that Rockstar,
what was that one that nobody went to see him?
Ricky get your gun or whatever the fuck that is.
Listen that wasn't art.
An art and Anderson Silva Front kick to the face is a thousand times more
beautiful than that piece.
Shit movie put out lady.
I know.
I'm sure she's a very nice person.
She probably thinks that she's,
she's standing up for what's right.
Get ready for Ricky.
Ricky Flash.
Get the fuck out of here.
Three people saw that movie and they're all related to her.
Nobody saw that movie.
Did you see that movie even heard of what the,
it was like,
what are they doing?
She's an 80 year old lady.
She's going to be a rockstar.
Ricky's coming back and,
but it's also like such weird casting for her too.
Cause like she does like these emotionally difficult like Sophie's choice
movies.
And then she's like trying to do like a poppy rock star movie.
Well she was interested in it.
You know,
she's an amazing actress.
She's an amazing artist in her realm.
And I just think it's the,
you could,
you could sort of say that without disparaging what other people enjoy and
including disparaging what a lot of women in joy and foreigners.
One of the things you were saying is that Hollywood is crawling with foreigners.
If you take them out,
all you have left is MMA and football and MMA.
Mixed martial arts is not the arts.
But you wouldn't,
that's not true because like 80% of the fighters in the UFC or from other
countries,
they're from Ireland.
Like Conor Mcgregor,
they're from Brazil,
like Amanda Nunez.
I mean this is the good,
incredibly diverse lineup of people from all over the world.
So for her to say that as like so silly,
but I,
I can understand saying that you don't think it's an art by your interpretation.
I understand that.
But the larger point is that humans are silly.
Humans in general are silly and we're not individually.
That's smart.
I think performance arts,
like as far as dance,
I mean their dance is clearly an art,
right?
If you watch Mikhail Baryshnikov,
that's clearly art.
And I think in many ways competition in performance,
like gymnastics is also an art.
We don't think of it as an art.
We think of it as a sport.
But when you look at the ability to execute these spectacular moves,
yeah,
maybe that doing it to a concerto,
but it's still art.
You know,
like you,
you see some amazing gymnast fly through the air and nail a landing.
It's beautiful.
It's glorious.
Well that's art in competition,
but it's not one on one competition.
Now art in one on one competition is Edson Barboza wheel kicking Terry Edem.
I know it doesn't look like art to some people,
but to me it does well and it's a technically extremely difficult move.
It's a lot of time to practice and get good at.
So it's just the fact that when he does his beautiful pair of flat,
it just lands in someone's face.
Well,
someone has to suffer and because someone has to suffer and perhaps sometimes
both people have to suffer in the in,
in terms of,
uh,
a very brutal fight.
Right.
But if you look at,
like Amanda Nunez is knock out of Ronda Rousey's if you're an Amanda Nunez Fan,
that is a beautiful work of art.
Yeah.
Cause she didn't get any promotion for that fight.
She was looked at like cannon fodder to go in there and fight rousy.
A lot of people were predicting a first round victory and she went out there and
fucked her up in 48 seconds.
Art Tool to some people,
it might not be to her,
but
[inaudible].